bienvenue à tous paris saclay tv n'a pas
encore pris la clé des champs nous
sommes à paris devant télécom paristech
cette école d'enseignement supérieur et
de recherche doit déménager sur le
plateau nous avons rencontré son
directeur il nous explique entre autres
l'importance de la ligne 18 cette future
ligne de métro nous reviendrons aussi
sur la cinquième édition de paris saclay
invest ça a été un franc succès autre
temps fort de l'actualité ni innovation
sommer quand une quarantaine d'étudiants
ont planché sur ce thème la ville de
demain
l'enseignement du future élite au coeur
de l'université de paris saclay vous
allez découvrir le bâtiment
d'enseignement mutualisé du quartier de
l'école polytechnique et enfin à la fin
de cette émission
notre agenda évidemment on commence donc
avec paris saclay un veste cinquième
édition et ce constat le succès est tel
que l'événement va devenir bi annuel
l'objectif reste le même mettre en
contact les entreprises et les
investisseurs
bienvenue à paris saclay un veste
session 2015 5e édition de cet événement
annuel qui devient d'ailleurs à partir
de cette année bi annuel le deuxième
événement aura lieu à la fin de l'année
au mois de décembre dans les locaux des
chaussées donc c'est une première que
nous faisons avec un objectif d'en faire
d'ailleurs 3 par an sur le territoire le
grand territoire paris-saclay s'agit des
10 meilleurs projets sélectionnés et six
derniers mois présenté ici au travers de
fiches dit pitch qui se présentent et
qu'ils peuvent a ensuite comme vous le
voyez autour de moi rencontrer
individuellement des investisseurs pour
pouvoir rassembler les financements
nécessaires à leur croissance et à leurs
ambitions de croissance
il ya un dynamisme créatif sur le
plateau qui se développent un qui n'est
pas nouveau ce que nous on fait ça
depuis 15 ans ici sur le plateau
donc c'est pas quelque chose de neuf
mais c'est quelque chose qui prend de la
vitesse dans une qualité des projets qui
augmente une qualité des porteurs de
projets qui augmente ça c'est la bonne
nouvelle
c'est un projet c'est surtout des
porteurs les pitchs son meilleur qualité
des projets en eux mêmes c'est quand ils
arrivent en comité de sélection chez
nous je reviens pas sur le process mais
notre association un process de
sélection et donc dans ce procès sont
voix des projets arrivait beaucoup mieux
préparés qu'avant les projets qu on
vraiment de l'ambition beaucoup plus
internationale aussi qu'avant donc une
qualité globale de projet qui est très
étonnante officiel c'est une start up
qui a été créé en 2013
notre objectif c'est de développer des
solutions numériques sur tablette pour
accompagner les personnes avec handicap
handicap cognitif ou mental vers
l'autonomie l apprentissage avec des
suites logicielles dédiées et adapté
nous on s'implique énormément en fait
pour que ce territoire soit un
territoire pionnier de l'innovation pour
les personnes qui ont un handicap etc
notamment pour ça qu'on a travaillé dans
le living lab participation sociale et
handicap qui est en train d'être mis en
place
formaliser avec le conseil général de
l'essonne l' agence pour l'économie en
essonne et le réseau petite vallée
l'idée c'est vraiment d'être une
référence nationale
donc on est très très contents parce que
la démarche de living lab et la démarche
de toutes façons de co-innovation plus
largement est essentiel dans la
conception d'outils adaptés pour les
personnes handicapées
ils n'ont pas encore monté leur petite
entreprise mais ils ont déjà plein
d'idées plein de projets une quarantaine
d'étudiants ont participé à l'innovation
sa marque amp
ils ont planché sur ce thème la ville de
demain une quarantaine d'étudiants qui
sont venus volontairement dans ce camp
pour vivre pendant une semaine une mise
en situation
deux créations éventuellement des
startups en tout cas d'avoir la bonne
idée de big eyes
cette semaine ils viennent de partout de
toutes les écoles ils ont des profils
très diversifiés
ce qui correspond en fait à une bonne
équipe pour des entreprises donc au
départ on leur donne des thématiques
donc aujourd'hui c'est la ville de
demain donc la planète les échanges
il avait un certain nombre de
thématiques pour démarrer ils ont eux
même imaginer des problématiques
éventuels qui sont allés vérifier tout
de suite dehors auprès des utilisateurs
et des gens qui potentiellement était
été soumis à cette problématique qu'ils
ont vérifié que c'était bien ce qu'ils
pensent et souvent ils ont ils ont vu
que c'était pas du tout ce qu'ils
pensaient ils sont venus avec d'autres
idées ils sont passés dans une étape on
appelle idéation elles ont imaginé des
solutions des concepts de solutions qui
sont repartis vérifier avec ses
utilisateurs ou avec d'autres
et une fois qu'ils ont une idée de
solutions dès le mercredi ils ont
commencé à prototyper donc on a un fab
lab
ils ont commencé à m'inquiéter alors
avec du carton et du polystyrène avec ce
qu'ils avaient sous la main et ils ont
mis à l'épreuve leurs prototypes
également avec des utilisateurs voir ici
c'est exactement ce qu'ils pensaient si
ça marchait pour certains ça a été
douloureux ils sont aperçus que bah non
c'est que ça existait déjà ou ça
marchait pas comme une pensée ça n'ait
pas marché
ils ont opéré ce qu'on appelle un pivot
ils sont dix ont une autre idée ils sont
partis ils ont eu un moment de morale
assez bas et il a fallu l'aider à
remonter à repartir sur autre chose
et hier soir ils ont tous été
soumis à la pression du temps savoir que
le jury est aujourd'hui vendredi et il
ya eu open fablab donc toute la nuit ils
ont travaillé donc ils ont mac était le
produit la solution est également le
business model comment ça va fonctionner
comment ils ont gagné de l'argent à qui
ils vont vendre quoi et c'est ce qu'ils
auront à présenter cet après midi grâce
à une courte vidéo
et puis une présentation de cinq minutes
devant un jury qui est constitué
d'entrepreneurs sur les a sous la main
ici notamment l'entrepreneur et
d'acteurs du plateau de saclay donc à
trois prix et le premier le premier prix
du jury sera un hébergement d'un an 1
503 avec l'accompagnement
pour mener à bien ce projet d'entreprise
qui dit ville de demain 10 universités
de demain celle de paris saclay un
enseignement high tech et l'
architecture qui va avec
vous allez découvrir le bâtiment
d'enseignement mutualisé du quartier de
l'école polytechnique
il abritera à terme six grandes écoles
comment at il été pensé conçu pour
quelle ambition
voyez ce reportage c'est un bâtiment
d'enseignement mutualisés comme son nom
l'indiqué est ce qui est mutualisé c'est
le bâtiment r c'est un bâtiment qui va
accueillir des étudiants venant de six
écoles qui seront toutes présentes dans
le quartier de l'école polytechnique
dans le cadre du grand projet
d'université paris saclay l'idée c'était
de créer un lieu fédérateur
un lieu de rassemblement est un symbole
de ce rapprochement
le projet est située sur une parcelle
longue et étroite dont la façade s'ouvre
généreusement sur le green de michel
desvigne nous souhaitions ne pas avoir
une limite claire entre intérieur et
extérieur
donc c'est ainsi que la nature rentrer
généreusement dans le coeur du bâtiment
nous avons de plus un réseau de
passerelles et d'escaliers qui vient lié
encore une fois extérieur et intérieur
le projet est aussi organisée sur un
plan très simple donc toutes les salles
de classe sont rejetés en arrière et
sont largement ouvertes sur ce coeur
ouvert de mener une réflexion sur
l'enseignement du futur qu'est ce que ça
veut dire de rassembler six écoles
qu'est ce que ça veut dire d'enseignés
aujourd'hui et demain
et de fait nous souhaitions privilégier
les espaces de rencontre et de partage
donc ce réseau de passerelles d'escalier
créer autant de lieux de rencontres
spontanées jeu projet est très
importante pour plusieurs raisons
d'abord parce que il apporte une
finition urbanistique au campus de
l'école polytechnique vers l'ouest dans
le futur grâce au projet d'université
paris saclay le l'entrée de l'école se
fera par l'ouest puisque la gare du
métro sera implanté dans le quartier de
danone de thales et supoptique la
deuxième raison pour laquelle ce
bâtiment est important c'est que il est
placé au contact de nos laboratoires de
recherche et qui va recréer le lien
entre l'enseignement et la recherche est
un lien très important
la troisième raison c'est effectivement
le fait qui nous permet de brasser dans
un même espace les élèves de six écoles
qui sont des écoles qui historiquement
ont toujours travaillé ensemble mais qui
seront encore plus unis dans le futur
c'est un réel défi parce qu'il s'agit de
donner un nouveau départ de données
nouvelle image cette université et
surtout pour nous c'était encore une
fois une réelle réflexion sur comment
répondre à ce sujet comment présenter
une vision pour le pour l'enseignant du
pit yeux
après l' architecture place aux
infrastructures avec la ligne 18 cette
future ligne de métro paris saclay tv
veut savoir ce que vous en pensez
aujourd'hui la parole et aux directeurs
des écoles d'enseignement supérieur et
de recherche qui sont appelés à
déménager sur le territoire c'est le cas
de télécom paristech qui nous
accueillent aujourd'hui voici quelques
témoignages
télécom paristech est aujourd'hui
implanté dans paris donc pour nous il
est absolument vital saclay on retrouve
la même accessibilité au centre de paris
que celle qu'on a aujourd'hui en plein
coeur de la ville
il est clair que paris saclay présente
des avantages considérables pour une
école comme la nôtre en terme d'éco
système et que la seule chose qui
aujourd'hui sur laquelle nous sommes
interpellés en tant que décideur c'est
et l'accessibilité à marcq des japonais
au personnel dans leurs trajets
quotidiens pour nos élèves qui ont envie
d'aller dans paris et puis je pense
aussi à nos visiteurs étrangers aux
visiteurs de quatre coins de la france
qui ont aussi besoin d'une accessibilité
facilitée à paris saclay le rayonnement
de paris saclay sera conditionnée par
son accessibilité
depuis les grandes gares parisiennes
depuis les grands aéroports parisiens et
la ligne 18 de ce point de vue là est
absolument absolument vital l'a pas mal
de tournois organisés durant l'année du
coup souvent les tournois vu qu'ils ont
besoin de place et de pas mal de terrain
et aux se font en dehors de paris est
justement là cette année le tournoi
paristech qui a lieu tous les ans s'est
fait sur le campus de l'x et donc pour
les gens qui parlent de paris ou quoi
c'est vachement compliqué donc là
avec cette ligne ça pourrait être cool
quoi n 18
c'est un projet qui est pour nous
indissociable de notre installation sur
le plateau de saclay dès l'origine
on ne pouvait pas concevoir de déplacés
l'établissement sans qu'ils aient des
moyens de transport à la bonne échelle
et en capacité et en qualité
bon en établissements comme l'école -
super de cachan c'est plus de 1000
étudiants c'est plus de 600 chercheurs
c'est plus de 200 professeurs ce sont
des personnels techniques et
administratifs qui viennent tous les
jours travailler à l'école ce sont des
milliers de visiteurs qui viennent
chaque mois donc il est inconcevable
évidemment d'installer un établissement
de cette nature dans un environnement
qui n'est pas correctement connectés non
seulement à paris mais aussi plus
généralement au monde
je pense qu'avec la ligne 18 c'est aussi
une manière de développer un
établissement sur un campus en
périphérie parisienne mais avec en même
temps une philosophie de transport qui
est compatible avec ce qu'on peut
attendre dans une université du 21e
siècle
on se quitte avec l'agenda et ses images
de l'alstom open de france la
compétition a lieu début juillet au golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
c'est une épreuve majeure du calendrier
de l'european taux est une première
étape vers la ryder cup qui aura lieu en
france en 2018
enfin notez que les universités d'été
enseignants entreprises se tiendront les
25 et 26 août à paris saclay thème
retenu pour cette douzième édition le
travail de demain et pour l'heure
profitez bien de vos vacances nous on se
retrouve très vite pour un nouveau
numéro de paris saclay tv et d'ici là
vous pouvez rester informé en allant sur
notre site pps point fr à bientôt